de nouvelles élections doivent donc
avoir lieu vous l'avez entendu dès
vendredi prochain une chose est sûre le
maire de Joué-lès-Tours Frédéric ogie
sera candidat à sa propre succession à
la tête de Tours métropole on en parle
tout de suite avec le principal
intéressé Frédéric oGIS bonjour bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
à présent et demi de crise cette
démission pour remettre toute ta place
c'était la seule solution c'était la
seule solution celle que je voulais
c'est à dire je pouvais pas demander à
des gens de revoir leur poste et pas moi
donc construit une nouvelle ambition
pour notre métropole passer déjà par la
réélection d'un Président j'ai présenté
ma démission avec la volonté de
représenter ma candidature vendredi
prochain 20h à la métropole vous savez
s'il y en aura d'autres des candidatures
c'est une élection il y aura pas celle
d'Emmanuel Denis en tout cas non parce
que vous avez pu voir
nous avons consigné pour une nouvelle
ambition pour cette métropole nous
avions pas réussi en 2021 à faire
rentrer toutes possibilité c'est ma
volonté ça a toujours été notre volonté
de trouver un accord
il était pas difficile à trouver parce
que on s'apprécie et ce que l'on veut
c'est faire gagner notre métropole mais
vous avez mis plus d'un an et demi à le
trouver cet accord puisqu'on se rappelle
de cette séquence ou l'opposition les
élus de gauche quitte la séance puisque
vous n'arrivez pas à vous mettre
d'accord sur un nombre de vices
présidents pour la gauche le
vice-président pour la gauche et là
aujourd'hui vous me dites bah en fait on
s'entend bien et c'est assez facile de
discuter
est-ce que vous quand vous êtes des
observateurs attentifs ils ont voté le
budget les mers
le projet RER métropolitain nous
rassemble il y a jamais eu de clash au
sein du Conseil métropolitain depuis un
an et demi dans les débats donc on peut
avoir on peut avoir des divergences mais
on n'a jamais franchi le Rubicon parce
que avant tout on aime tous cette
métropole on doit être à la hauteur de
cette ambition que l'on a eu en héritage
alors si vous aujourd'hui vous vous
représentez en tant que président et que
vous avez le soutien du maire de Tours
Emmanuel Denis ça veut dire j'imagine il
y a eu des arrangements la première
vice-présidence de la métropole elle est
d'ores est déjà pour lui on dit au
revoir à Marielle épine
c'est pas contre des personnes c'est au
contraire avec tout le monde donc c'est
pas ce soir qu'on va décider cela j'ai
présenté ma démission était décidé
j'imagine que un poste a moins été
réservé à Emmanuel Denis la poste est
pour Emmanuel Denis parce que
il a un poste a été dévolu à Emmanuel
mais on a parfois peut-être trop
anticipé les personnes et les
portefeuilles avant les élections donc
première élection vendredi soir le
président et ensuite l'ensemble de
l'exécutif et l'ensemble de ce qu'il
faut robotter on va pas faire deux
élections on fait une soirée de
réinstallation de tous les postes qui a
besoin de remettre en jeu et on se met
au travail mais la plupart des personnes
qui sont autour de la table de la
métropole connaissent les dossiers sont
prêts à travailler et on s'est envie de
travailler ensemble alors si il faut
intégrer de nouveaux vices présidents il
va falloir les briefer dans leur
nouvelle fonction transmettre les
dossiers est-ce que là encore on va pas
perdre du temps dans l'avancée de ces
dossiers
on perdra pas de temps on va même en
gagner on va elle encore aller plus vite
plus fort parce que nos habitants nous
le demandent soyons la hauteur nous
sommes tous enclin à faire une fin de
mandat sur les chapeaux de roue pour
bien montrer que notre territoire il est
bien placé et si on le fait pas d'autres
territoires prendre notre place ça veut
dire que vous avez réussi à trouver des
vices présidents qui pour ça pour cette
ambition là sont prêts à laisser leur
place à la gauche nous pourquoi j'ai
démissionné c'est justement pour pas
faire de la cuisine à partir du moment
où le président démissionne c'est
l'ensemble de l'exécutif qui a été
démissionné et on remet tout à plat il y
a eu des négociations il y a forcément
eu de la cuisine en interne entre vous
et manuel Denis
parce que c'est pas des moi je n'ai
jamais vu comme une négociation de la
tambouille parce que j'aime pas ça ça a
été qu'est-ce que l'on veut pour la
métropole qu'est-ce que l'on veut pour
les grands projets et qu'est-ce que l'on
veut pour nos habitants le gagnant ce
soir s'appelle tour métropole Val de
Loire et donc on aura toutes nos
réponses vendredi soir à partir de 20h
c'est ça dans une semaine voilà quel
magnifique merci beaucoup Frédéric Ozil
bienvenue à répondre à nos questions